another premiere on Neil Patrick Harris
hit the red carpet in New York City
looking like Neil Patrick Harris but in
the new Netflix series Lemony Snicket's
A Series of Unfortunate Events he is
almost unrecognizable hello children I'm
always intrigued by interesting content
you know in an interesting challenge and
a new weird skill set to take on Neil
plays Count Olaf who attempts to steal
an inheritance from orphan children by
creating some elaborate disguises why do
you hate us so much because it's fun and
they all required hours of makeup every
day so all day long someone's just
poking at your face literally nine hours
of someone between takes just Neil told
us he actually wore a different cologne
for each one do you know what this is it
looks like a list wrong it's a list
Olaf smelt very much leather and burnt
fire smoke why he's very handsome
captain sham was doused in sad Old Spice
I think and it was a real physical
transformation character wise and I got
to be a total blundering horrible idiot
but would he bring Count Olaf and his
evil ways home to meet his own kids I
like to always do things with a tongue
and firmly planted in my cheek at least
with the kids that way if I'm being
reprimanded or getting really serious at
least I can still give them a little bit
of a wink and let them know that I'm
upset but not going to destroy them
you